[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had arrived at
this equation
involving the unknown scalar function f
as well as the unknown
deflection w so this is a single
equation containing the two unknowns f
and w
and so we have to find another equation
question is
what do we do to find another equation
because we have already proceeded by the
by the root of the virtual work equation
to arrive at this
what else do we use to arrive at another
governing differential equation
well you see the clue lies in the
presence
of this scalar function f
all right so the clue is like this
that back in applied elasticity when we
were doing those problems in 2d
elasticity in fact when we had
derived those formulations resulting in
in this bioharmonic equations both in
the case of plane stress and plane
strain
uh one important thing which we had to
ensure
while going down the root of the airy
stress function
is that we have to ensure the
compatibility
okay because that was the stress
function approach
we were proceeding via a route which
would
help us determine directly the stresses
so it was not uh it was it was not a
governing differential equation for the
displacement that we were arriving at
rather it was the governing differential
equation
for the area stress function which would
lead to the stresses so in that
situation we had to actually
ensure that the compatibility equations
were satisfied now one might argue
that we do have an equation here
involving the displacements
okay and that was uh
and then that is certainly true but at
the same time we do have a part of the
of this setup uh having the presence of
this
uh scalar function which is working like
the
or which is like the counterpart of that
airy stress function
of a blood elasticity so uh it perhaps
makes sense for us
to uh to try to go down the route
of uh ensuring the compatibility of the
equation and let's see
uh how in my how it might give us
another
governing differential equation okay but
we have to be a little bit careful here
uh and you will see why why the reason
or why the motivation for that
carefulness
okay so let me go to the new page and
start off the specific compatibility
equation that i am going to deal with
is this one del square epsilon xx
i'm not going to the details of this too
much here because
these discussions were already
we'd already had this discussions back
in applied elasticity
so i'm just going to uh utilize this
so we have this compatibility equation
okay now if you are a little bit
observant
you should immediately point out that
uh we have written down this
compatibility equation but it has no
real place
in this particular um theoretical
development
and the reason is that here we are
actually using
not these small strains or these
infinitesimal strains
rather the large strings which do
involve the non-linear terms
so what do we do we should not directly
be using these
or so so no matter
what we'll do is uh we will simply write
down the connection between
the small strains or these infinitely
strains and
those and the large strains that we're
actually dealing with so we
so we note that e x x this is the one
which we are really interested in as
part of our formulation
and that is just the infinite small
string
added by this extra term
so you can easily see this if you go
back to the very first page
or perhaps the second page of of this
of these uh lecture slides uh
in terms of the videos uh it was present
in the uh in the first part of the of
the introduction and
and derivation part one uh of the one
common plate theory
series okay next for the
e y y we have epsilon y y
plus half del w
del y square and for f
for e x y we have its connection with
the
epsilon x y in this fashion
that's it
so all that we have to do is to go back
to this compatibility equation
and substitute these epsilon x x epsilon
y y and epsilon x y
in terms of this e x x e y y and e x y
okay so so from here
what we're going to obtain is this thing
so i'm skipping a step here del square e
x
x del y square minus of del square del y
square of this entire thing
so that's the first term for this second
term
we'll have del square e
yy del x square
minus del square del x
square and then this term
and on the right hand side
we are going to have del square e x y
[Music]
del x del y
minus twice
del square del x del y
half del w del x
del w del y so basically this step
okay now this looks like a horrible mess
up well
it is going to become a little bit
simpler but first we have to note
that we don't want to keep it like this
because within this ex
if you go back um to the
to the earlier pages you'll see that we
have already expressed this e
x x uh in terms of
the the e x x naught uh
which was independent of the z d
in z dependence and uh and other terms
which had some z dependence
okay so let me just go back and
so
[Music]
sorry about that
[Music]
so uh we had this in these relations so
e x
x is equal to e x x naught minus z del
square w del x
square similarly for e y y and e x y so
this is what we are going to
utilize now if we do that
okay if we do that and expand and
simplify
uh what we are going to end up with
uh is something like this
let me get back to this page so if i do
all that
i'll end up with
[Music]
let me write that down first and then
i'll
[Music]
i'll discuss it a little bit
foreign
okay you see in going from this
step to this step it is not something
that i have done
mentally again i have written this down
in a piece of paper separately and then
i just copied from there
because going from here to here it is
not just a matter of substitution
of this e x x in terms of the c x s
naught and the other terms
rather there is a considerable amount of
simplification going on
in these terms involving the w's okay
so it's not it's not just a trivial
one-step affair in going from this step
to this step you do have to go through a
few steps
uh and do some simplifications in order
to arrive at this
okay so what i'm going to do is
uh i'm going to give
this part uh this this particular
simplification
going from this step to this step as uh
an exercise in your problem sheet
uh and you can do that of course there's
not much mechanics involved in that
there's no mechanical understanding it's
just you know simple calculus and
algebra so i believe
all of you can do it on your own so let
me move on to things which do involve
uh advanced mechanics of solids uh and
uh which will ultimately help us to
obtain the governing differential
equation all right so going to the next
page
uh what how do we how do you proceed
from here to the governing differential
equation because you see
my motivation here is not to just play
around with this compatibility equation
i my motivation here is to use the
compatibility equation to somehow arrive
at
terms which would uh which would
help me obtain an equation involving
this w
which i already have here but also
involving somehow
uh the f
okay remember that f the scalar function
which we had obtained
uh in the previous or which were written
in the previous video
so that one so i want to arrive at an
equation
involving the f and the w i already have
one equation so i
i want to end up finally with two
equations involving the f and w so which
i can solve simultaneously so how do we
go from here
well the clue uh is here
in the pre through these terms the e x x
not the e y naught
and the e x y naught by themselves they
do not have any connection with the f
but suppose we were to uh we were to
write these
in terms of the sigma xx
sigma yy and sigma xy and then perhaps
there would be some form of uh
of carrying out the uh the connection
or or or link or or establishing the
connection with the
uh with the f okay so let's proceed a
little bit
what i'm going to do next uh is to
reconsider the expression
for the nx okay because that actually
contains
within it the sigma xx and we'll see how
how we
finally make this connection
with the e x x naught etc
so this is what we have now
this sigma xx
using the constitutive relation i have
this as
[Music]
the sigma x x is e by 1 minus nu square
e x x plus
nu e y y so again
i am using uh whatever we had discussed
back in our uh chapter on 2d elasticity
uh from our course of applied elasticity
okay so if you have forgotten those
things uh
the kinds of of reduced considerable
equations that we
that we obtained uh in the case of the
plane stress
and the reduced constitutive equations
that we obtain in the case of plane
strain
i strongly strongly advise you to please
go back to those video lectures
and take a look and i'll try to put in
the link
in the video description below all right
so uh so once we have these things uh
we can hope to make a
make a connection with whatever we had
written in the previous page
because we know that this e x x
is
[Music]
this e x x is e x x naught
minus z del square w del x
square and this one
here can be written as e
y y naught minus
mu z del square w
del y square
d said okay
now uh again you note that this this
particular term by itself the del square
w del x
squared and the del square w del y
square because w
is a pure function of x and y that can
come out of this
integration with respect to
[Music]
with respect to z and this z and this
set is the only thing remaining
and that if you integrate from minus h
by 2 to h by 2 that will just give us
a 0. so effectively this gives us 0
this gives us a 0 and what we'll be left
with in the next step
is just this term
[Music]
[Music]
all right now uh what we're going to say
is that you see this e x x naught
and e y naught they are independent of z
so we might as well take them out of
this integration
and if we do that then what we'll be
left with is this integration minus h by
2 to h by 2 dz
and that is nothing but h so ultimately
what we arrive at
is this e h divided by 1 minus nu square
e x x naught plus nu e
y y naught and what we say is that
just like in the classical plate theory
we had arrived at a term
uh like e h cubed by 12
uh one minus nu squared we had denote we
had called that uh
as d the pending rigidity so also this
uh thing will be we will just write as c
okay so overall this nx is c
e x x naught plus
nu e y y naught
all right okay so this was about n x
in exactly the same fashion we can
arrive at uh similar expressions for
n y and n x y so let me just uh
without going through all these details
uh let me just go to the next page and
write those
things together so an x
is equal to c e x
x naught plus nu
e y y naught
[Music]
and y is equal to c
[Music]
e y y naught plus nu
e x x naught
[Music]
and n x y is equal to
c into 1 minus nu
e x y naught
now all that we have to do because you
see our ultimate motivation here is to
uh is to go back to that version of the
compatibility equation which we had left
earlier so this equation and we want to
up
to rewrite these e x x naught e y y
naught e x y naught in terms of this
n x y n y and n x y so now
all they have to do is invert these
relations okay
so if uh if we if we just do a little
bit of algebra
and invert these relations
[Music]
what we are going to obtain is
e x x naught is equal to
[Music]
x x naught is equal to 1 by
e h
and x minus nu
and y
[Music]
e y y naught is equal to
1 by e h and y
minus nu nx
and e x y naught is equal to
1 plus nu in in the numerator
divided by e h multiplied
by n x y okay
so
now if we just take these expressions
and substitute them uh in that earlier
equation
meaning this equation okay
if we just substitute here
let me just try to copy this thing
so substitute in the following
[Music]
then the equation that we are going to
end up with
okay so that is not a very complicated
step i'll just write it down
so i can utilize this page itself here
[Music]
so i'll end up with 1 by e h
sorry about that
1 by e h
[Music]
del square n x del y
square minus
nu del square
and y
[Music]
del y square so from this one
and substituting these things
next uh substituting the e y naught from
here
i'll obtain del square
n y del x square
minus nu del square n x
del x square
[Music]
and then
[Music]
minus 2 1 plus nu so basically this one
l squared and x y
del x del y close the square bracket
and on the right hand side whatever i
have here i
i just write that okay so
del square w del x
del y
[Music]
square of the whole thing minus del
square w
del x square del square w
del y square
so all that you have to do now is to
just now
go back and look at the expressions for
this n x
and y and n x y in terms of
the scalar function f so this n x
was del square f del
uh y square
and y was del square f del x square and
this n x y
was minus del square f del x del y
so if you substitute that okay so
substitute all these things
[Music]
then the equation that we are finally
going to obtain is
the harmonic of f okay so
again i'm not doing this by one mental
um i mean i'm not just doing this
mentally in one step
but uh i have already done this thing so
i know what the expression is
so this is it ultimately simplifies to
this by harmonic of
f is equal to e h
so that eh goes to the right hand side
and whatever
is present here
[Music]
okay and now you see starting from the
compatibility equation we have arrived
at this
this other governing equation which also
involves
both this unknown w as well as this
unknown
uh scalar function f so let me square
let me just put this
within a box because this is the
governing equation
that we wanted the other governing
equation that we wanted
so now if i go back
this was the first governing equation
[Music]
so please note that this is referred to
this is referred to as the first
[Music]
purple
one common equation
and this one is referred to as the
second
[Music]
so whenever we have to solve a problem
of which
where there is a possibility of some
buckling then we have to deal with
both these four one common equations
simultaneously
please note that uh in this entire thing
i have not actually gone back and taken
a look
at the
so just hang on
at this uh the boundary terms
so so i i will end up
with certain boundary terms also okay
you see that i have just written down
the governing differential equation here
by considering this overall thing i have
not actually considered
these boundary terms here they are they
are left unconsidered so it is
only when we deal with certain specific
problems that will have to
deal with those boundary terms uh at
this point i do not want to write those
down
in their full generality okay but the
most important thing is that
unlike classical plate theory where we
arrived at one
at a single equation uh
involving the deflection here in the
purple one common plate theory we have
two equations
uh involving both the w and the f uh you
also please note
that uh if i just consider this
first uh the first one common equation
then
then this here
i mean
[Music]
these are the extra things present
really compared to the classical plate
theory
these are really the extra things which
are present
[Music]
please note that i just i just noticed
that there is a little bit of a sign
mistake here
and that goes back to the first to the
previous video also
i'll just correct it out very quickly so
uh back when we were doing this uh
so you see that on the on the second
part of this lh is there was this minus
sign
and on this first part of this lhs also
there was this minus sign on
uh on this term this outside minus
sitting here so when i wrote the
the governing differential equation the
third part here which was the
coefficient of
delta w there should really have been a
minus sign in front of all of these
okay so there should have been a minus
sign in front of all of these so i just
correct this
and there was this mystic on the right
hand side which i had corrected in this
in the second step
that this q was uh absent okay so
i'll make this correction in the next
step also sorry about that
all right so if we proceed like that
well there will be a minus here also
there will be one
this will be within the bracket and
this thing uh well i simplified it a
little bit
um
there would be a minus here
[Music]
and now when i substitute this thing i
would have
a minus here
but since i already have this thing with
a minus
these all these terms involving the m
and this itself is a minus d
del 4 w so this would become a plus
okay so uh the first of the
one common equations well uh this comes
with a plus here
and
this is a
minus this also is a
it's a minus
and of course this is a plus
all right uh so with this correction uh
we have
uh the two four plus one common
equations
this is the first one and and as we have
just
derived it this is the second one so on
that note i'll end this video
thank you very much